another day another expletive filled
twitter exchange between chrissy teigen
and president donald trump it's
ridiculous all because of twitter and
this time things got really ugly here's
what went down on Sunday the president
hopped on his go-to social media
platform to deliver a lengthy series of
tweets about not getting enough credit
for the passage of criminal justice
reform legislation after watching
MSNBC's final installment of leicester
holds justice for all series which
featured john legend if you want to get
involved some more get involved with
free america my organization or any
other organization in your community
naturally he took the opportunity to
swing at Chrissy and her hubby and in
trouble again for something Trump wrote
in part quote when all of the people
pushing so hard for criminal justice
reform were unable to come even close to
getting it done they came to me as a
group and asked for my help I got it
done but now that it is past people that
had virtually nothing to do with it are
taking the praise guys like boring
musician John Legend and his filthy
mouths wife are talking now about how
great it is but I didn't see them around
when we needed help getting it passed
yeah you heard that right
he said filthy mouth Dwight I'm learning
to let things roll off my back a lot
easier well maybe not so much because
Chrissy responded leaning into the
president's insult big time with this
not-safe-for-work tweet quote lol what
up tagged everyone but me and honor mr.
president later Chrissy shared this pic
of herself making a chalkboard sign to
celebrate the start of her daughter
Lunas second year of preschool she
captioned the shot quote Luna remember
the night before your first day of
school when mommy was making your sign
and the President had his ninth meltdown
of the day John also shot back at the
leader of the free world with a plea to
the first lady Melania Trump quote
imagine being president of a whole
country and spending your Sunday night
hain't watching MSNBC hoping somebody
anybody will praise you Melania please
praise this man he needs you your
country needs you Melania I think at
this point he just thinks it's so silly
that I even put any stake into what
anyone says online all Chrissie then
took to her Instagram stories to let
fans know how she was reeling sharing
this clip of her eating a big bowl of
pasta alongside the caption when the
president tweets about you
[Music]